hey everybody welcome to metaphysical
milkshake uh it is me rayne wilson and
it is i
reza aslan grammatically correct oh
listen we've got a question today about
music and we really
need
uh someone to answer it where does music
come from there's such a beautiful
mysterious mystic quality to
where music itself you know the the song
of the cosmos actually comes from who
are we gonna find to discuss this with
us
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
you may not know this about me but
i i used to be in a band i used to be in
a rock band you were in a band i had
life as a musician in my early 20s
seriously you were in a band in your
early 20s i was in a band yeah i was a
lead singer band called pike it's not a
joke pipe i have a look i have a photo
right here right here of me
in my emma band pike it was it was the
90s everybody anybody with a guitar was
in a band in the 90s why were you named
after a fish
it's not a not a fish it's moral about
the the spear and
you know why were you named after a
sphere i don't really i don't want to
get too deep into it we just we were
called pike it had some jesus
connotations let's move on anyway wait
wait wait wait wait wait are you were
you in a christian rock band well i
i wouldn't call it a christian rock band
it was a it was a rock band and we
happen to be christians those are
different those are two different did
you ever play a gig outside of a church
yes
did we also play gigs in church yes okay
so see there's a difference no it's pike
it's not
was jesus poked with a pike is that what
what how does that work what's i don't
get kind of a long it's sort of there's
a there's a it's a long circuitous
spiritual connection but look it it's
very much like the kinds of songs that
we sang you know our songs were
were the kinds of songs that you know
well look it could have been about jesus
it could have been about a girl who
knows it could have been either that
would be a great game show uh question
wouldn't it kind of like you have to
choose you know you have to pick like is
this a song about jesus or a song about
love like
your love lifts me up to the clouds like
this could be jesus could be a girl i'm
gonna say that one is definitely jesus
yeah that was jesus i want to be on my
knees all night
that that one could be either like it
could be that's kidding you got a girl
that's getting points
yeah i don't know about that but what
you're telling me right now is that you
could be the authority to talk to us
about where music comes from because you
were in the early 90s christian rock
band pike
all i'm saying is if we're going to have
a conversation about where music comes
from is it like a divinely inspired
thing does it come from within is it
about
you know accessing some frequency out
there or is it about just simply sitting
down and doing the grind you know we
have a rock star
in our midst we don't need to go and
find one but where are we going to get a
rock star anyway i mean honestly like
what rock star is going to come on our
our podcast well uh as a matter of fact
uh my good friend uh jason isbell
uh maybe you've heard of him the
guardian described his songwriting as
honest reflections about southern
identity and working class life that are
rarely glamorous but always incisive in
their disenchantment yes the jason
isabel whose song maybe it's time was in
your favorite movie a star is born wait
a minute are you talking about four-time
grammy winner singer songwriter and
guitarist jason
why would
four-time grammy winner jason isabel be
on our podcast that doesn't make any
sense at all
because
i called in a favor but first before we
go to jason i need to hear some pike
give us give us a taste uh
i need to hear some pike right now
maybe afterwards ladies and gentlemen
as was said earlier four-time grammy
winner singer songwriter great human
being and american jason isbell is here
welcome to metaphysical milkshake
i'm happy to be here i i admire you both
and i'm happy to speak with you today
listen before we get started i mean i
don't want to like put rain on the spot
or anything but you should just know
that
he's a really big fan of yours he likes
weird music
yeah i mean you could tell you could
tell just by the way he looks right now
he's trying not to be like all fan gushy
okay i like it when he's blushing
southeastern is an album i've listened
to um
as much or more than any other album
that i own
up there
with as many listens as let's go with
like blonde on blonde and uh wow okay
computer
and uh a handful of other
uh amazing albums that is a pantheon
right there that's big yeah rolling
stones list of top 10 country albums for
2013. that doesn't do it justice
it's a lot bigger than that that's
actually an interesting place to start
jason like so often people refer to you
as a country music
star or a country musician i i just
wonder like how you feel about that i
mean does that do you feel like that
kind of boxes you in in a genre that
sure of course you know it it's an
influence and
uh and some of your songs definitely
have like a country feel to them but how
do you feel when someone calls you a
country musician well when they call me
a country star you know i have to figure
out which is more wrong the the country
part or the star part
um
uh i'm you know i'm a country person i
guess by default uh but i don't
necessarily think i make country music i
make music that is influenced by country
music but probably
equally influenced by
rock and roll music and blues music and
and rnb music which a lot of people
mistakenly call soul music and you know
i i don't think it's a a a pretty i
don't think it's a genre kind of thing
um
uh you know i try to stay away from
things that i don't feel
uh qualified to create um
you know so so i'm making some form of
my
type of music which is which is a
combination of all the things that i
like but i i don't consider myself
really a country music singer you grew
up in the south
obviously right was it alabama alabama
all the way all the way in that's what
the south calls the south yes exactly
yeah that's a southerner south how much
of that that environment being in the
south how much of that
um went into the kind of
emotional intelligence of the music that
you write i think a lot of it you know i
had i had a conversation earlier uh with
a friend of mine adia victoria who's a
who's a country singer and a blues
singer from the south and
and uh she she and i were talking about
these same things earlier um
but you know we came to the point that
when you grow up in a sort of religious
southern background i was an only child
and i spent a lot of time with my
grandparents my parents were were
teenagers when i was born so they were
always working real hard and when i was
when i was really little we lived in a
trailer in my grandmother's yard a
single wide right next to her driveway
and um
so i spent the majority of my time for
you know during the school year either
walking home to my grandparents house or
you know in the summer i would stay with
my grandparents
and and they had gardens and they had
farm animals and and they also had a lot
of religion my grandfather was a
holiness pentecostal preacher wow and uh
yeah so it was serious it was speaking
in tongues serious stuff and um
every
part of nature
had some uh
metaphorical connection
to the story of the passion you know and
and and every every flower every animal
every
plant every tree everything has
something to do with jesus and
i think the lessons that stuck with me
throughout my life from that were
lessons of awareness and lessons of this
sort of metaphorical connection to
nature that our human psyche has you
know and it and it fed a narrative that
i think
um a lot of southern writers and artists
and musicians fall into this kind of
story where you know i can use these
roses and these trees and these flowers
in the same way that you know they were
used in religion for me when i was a a
child um
so i do think that there are a lot of
advantages i had growing up there and
being a songwriter and an artist later
on you know plus everybody's gotta if
you're gonna if you're gonna play music
and write music you gotta get the blues
one way or another you know you have to
get your own version of it and uh
being a weirdo kid in front of a bunch
of macho alabama kids was my version of
that very often i think you know the the
topic of our conversation is like where
does music come from and obviously we're
starting with you with some of the
personal like who's jason isabel where
does it come from
culturally
historically environmentally
personally i'd love to hear more about
i know you've talked about it a lot but
how unsobriety and drinking culture
influenced your music early on and how
sobriety influences your music later but
since you brought up the pentecostal
thing that's something that is really
because reza and i are both you know
religious scholars he's a professional
religious scholar i'm an amateur but
you know
this this pentecostal idea and
pentecostalism you know brought music
really hardcore into the churches
yeah they had live electric music like
rock bands nowadays whether you're a
christian or not you know that like most
churches you go there and it's like
drums and a guitar and there's like a
huge worship and everybody's dancing and
going crazy and stuff and people don't
realize
pentecostalism invented that like before
pentecostalism
singing at church was
a mighty fortresses
oh yeah that must have been
for somebody who you know obviously had
this childhood love of music to to
see
that in church married to spirituality
and religion and and and i love what you
were saying how like everything is a
metaphor for the passion of christ
you know i mean that must have had a
huge effect on you right it was yeah
that was everything that was everything
you know and uh
i have managed to leave most of the
guilt and the shame behind me on the
path but i kept i kept the holy ghost
fire you know um i'm not a a
particularly religious person uh but i i
did keep that sort of
you know magic
alive in a lot of ways and that was how
i bonded with my family like i was super
close to my
my grandparents you know even when i was
15 16
17 years old because i i'd grown up
playing music with them we we we played
music together and we watched baseball
because those were the that was the only
thing we could watch where nobody would
say
the f word or show of titty or anything
you know so we we watched baseball and
we played music together and um
and we got along even in the ages where
you don't usually want to spend time
with your grandparents and it was
because of that like they understood uh
the rock and roll part of their
spirituality and so they understood the
rock and roll part of me a little bit
better but going even broader
what is this connection between you
talked about the fire of the holy ghost
and uh i love that because
really we'll get to this later but the
holy spirit
isn't that just analogous to the muses
of ancient greece but
why do you think music goes hand in hand
with worship what is it about the the
passion of music how how music opens us
up that from human the beginning of
human history there's been dancing and
music going hand in hand with worship
you you've rarely had worship without it
yeah that's how we keep the record
you know that's how we write it down
when we don't know how to write
we don't have anything to write on
we sing it we sing it and that way we
remember it and then when we sing it you
know uh rhythm has a has a a an organic
connection with
with uh how you feel and how your brain
feels and how you move and that part is
just i think uh biology i think you
can't help but you know
your heart rate elevates and it brings
something out of you but i think
originally we sang it to remember it you
know and i think that's the part that's
really
sort of sacred to me about music because
you know growing up in alabama the way i
did i didn't know any black people you
know we were all just poor white people
you know and and by poor i mean uh you
know fine but uh you know we were all in
the same boat down there and everybody
was working and nobody was ahead we had
what we needed but
but we were a a a very um sort of
exclusionary sort of community down
there and i didn't know anybody who
looked different from me until i got
into high school so
you know growing up down there
the only exposure i had to the black
american experience was was that music
and i started listening to that and
thinking oh no no no what i've heard
about these folks can't be true you know
because the truth of it is they feel
like this and if they feel like this and
they sound like this
then then they got to be more like me
than they are different from me that's
because they were keeping the record
then they were tell they were passing
that information to me i was not going
to go
pick up and read
a book about it but i was going to
listen to the music you know that's
that's yeah that makes so much sense
this idea that like
the emotion that's being conveyed by
these different genres
played by different you know
races different ethnicities
it becomes so familiar that you think to
yourself well i felt that i felt that so
must not be that much separating us i
guess yeah that was how it was was for
me and then i started going and reading
about it and actually getting to know
people and asking the questions and but
where i grew up that was just not in the
town green hill alabama there was nobody
but white kids you know
and so my first exposure to anybody's
life that was different from mine was
through music and
then i understood oh okay this is how
they get the truth across to people who
wouldn't listen otherwise you know i
tell you when i have a memory of a trip
to the south visiting friends and
every sunday
for some reason we would drive down this
one road and sunday 10 a.m
one church on one side of the road
parking lot full of black folks
walking into a church exactly other side
of the road parking lot full of white
families going into a church across the
road so close 100 yards away
but couldn't be more far apart yeah i
went into a restaurant once in
a part of the south when i was on tour
20 years ago when i first started
touring um
and it was a soul food restaurant but it
was also a country cooking restaurant
so they had two different menus and two
different rooms like separated by like a
dividing wall if you were into home
cooking you went over to this side and
if you're into soul food you went over
to this side and the food was the same
it was the same food
it was the same food everybody was just
sitting in different sides of the room
eating the same food well it was the
same food in those two churches as well
exactly exactly
you know there's so much going on in the
world right now whether it's stuff
you're excited about like the start of
the nfl season
or it's stuff you'd rather not think
about like a
global crippling pandemic that won't go
away but you know what you can control
rain what can you control you can
control the vibes in your head with a
pair of raycon wireless earbuds in your
ears whether you use them to pump up
wind down work or work out raycons
are our
go-to for the on-the-go audio and the
new everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever then improved rubber
oil look and feel they're very sleek
they're small too i really like how
small they are the optimized gel tips
for the perfect in-ear fit and they're
impressive and before you even start
listening
you get three sound profiles to make
sure everything you're listening to
sounds at its best with just the right
amount of bass and raycons most
importantly start at half the price of
other premium audio brands but they
sound just as good if not better and
raycons come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee so right now metaphysical
milkshake listeners can get 15 off their
recon order at buy raycon dot com slash
milkshake that's by raycon dot com slash
milkshake to save 15
on your new raycons
b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n
dot com slash milkshake
but go going back to your childhood you
know rain brought up this really
interesting connection between
um this idea of like
the holy spirit you know the mu the holy
spirit uh uh coming down and and
inspiring you and then in pentecostalism
you brought this up um there's also this
notion of speaking in tongues or just
like sort of free form
speaking because you are you are sort of
not in control of your own
imagination and your and your creativity
it's sort of it comes from the divine
right it's it's god that comes upon you
and the music is almost spontaneous in a
way and he's right that that's exactly
what the ancient greeks believed right
that was the whole point of the the
muses the the nine goddesses who you
know were like the inspiration for all
the arts and
sciences
and
there so
and by the way it's not just the greeks
you know you said it yourself this the
concept of of music was always thought
of as a divine function right who who
were the first uh musicians uh well it
was like the shaman right they would
they would record
um the story of the tribe and they would
repeat it in in verse
you know with a melody
so
from the very beginning there seems to
be this kind of
notion regardless of the specific
religion or culture or time period that
we are not the ones who originate
this
creative thing right called music or or
even just art in general that it comes
from some outside source
you know whether it's the muses or
whether it's the holy spirit or whatever
the case may be that our job is to
essentially
just
um
tune in to that frequency that's out
there already and that if we can just
tune in correctly whether we pray to the
muses or whether we open our hearts to
jesus whatever the case may be then
that's where
the
the creative process begins outside of
us right not not within us
how much of that do you think
rings true to you in so far as the way
that you have created music created art
i think if we tell the normies the truth
they'll kill us
[Laughter]
we have to come up with something you
know what god maybe do god made me do
this
they don't understand it so they think
we're working some kind of black magic
man
i love this and they'll burn us at the
stake you know um
i think that we we don't give ourselves
enough credit as a collective
consciousness you know um the way we
pass information to each other and the
way we innovate and create as a as a
species i think is is infinitely
beautiful and you know
a lot of people that i care about would
probably disagree with me on that but
i think we do a much better job than we
give ourselves credit for just as humans
i think that all that can be contained
within the human communal experience
frane you're an actor you've had this
experience i think all artists have had
this experience where like you do
something you create something
and you have no idea where it came from
yeah yeah you could be under torture and
you couldn't tell you you couldn't say
where it actually came from or how you
came up with that decision right right
yes i mean i do that as a as an actor
i'm sure you do as a writer reza but um
you know you do this preparation you
make plans how you're going to play a
character or something like that and
then
you find something spontaneously and you
don't know where it came from i'll i'll
tell you a little story here's a fun
little story this is kind of what got me
started acting so i at my high school in
chicago new trier high school had a very
advanced acting program i had moved
there from blue collar suburban seattle
there was this rich high school in
chicago and i started acting and one of
the high school plays they did was
pygmalion by george bernard shaw so it
was really highfalutin play and i was
playing alfred doolittle the cockney
working class kind of philosopher father
let's see the cockney accent
oh hello liza it's me alfred doolittle
your father oh i say governor uh we've
got to we've got some trouble brewing
ahead how was that i believe it i
totally believe it that's kind of how i
did it i did a lot of like
this kind of rolling my shoulders anyway
here i am first night in front of an
audience
and i'm doing a monologue and i'm there
and i'm i'm acting as alfred doolittle
the set decoration had put a little bowl
with chocolates on the table and i kind
of finished my spiel
saw the bowl
picked it up and dumped the chocolates
into my pocket and put the bowl back
down on the table i had never rehearsed
it i didn't think about it i didn't plan
it it just felt like a good idea at the
time for old alfred do a little to do it
it got raucous laughter we had to hold
we had to stop the play
and that's kind of when the penny
dropped for me i was kind of like holy
[ __ ] there is
there's something to this i don't know
what that was but whatever that moment
was i want to be a part of that i want
to do that i don't know the rehearsing
and the memorizing lines and all this
other stuff but i want to be a part of
that moment where there's
magic
i think that there's a lot about um our
unconscious mind that we don't
understand
and it's it's
you know it's easier to say that's magic
than to say i just don't know how my
brain is working right now um
but i do think that
you know there is in all the chaos that
there are patterns and that you can
sometimes find yourself
riding a wave it's like when you're
playing blackjack like i know you guys
know if you're playing blackjack and
there's six decks of cards your odds for
every single hand should really be the
same they should be pretty close to
identical whether you're playing at the
top of the shoe the middle of the shoe
or the end of the shoe but if you've
ever sat and played blackjack for days
on end uh like some of us degenerates
i'm i'm speaking for a friend i don't
know but if you've ever sat in a casino
for way too long you know that that
there are runs in luck and then that if
you know when to bet the odds are gonna
they're gonna play out differently and i
think that sometimes if our sense of
awareness is where it needs to be and if
we're living in the moment and if our
heads and our asses are in the same
place like they used to tell me in rehab
we catch one of those waves and we ride
one of those little
veins of gold inside all the chaos you
know that's how i look at it but it's
inside you know i i like i like the way
that you're talking about this because
look collective consciousness that in
and of itself is kind of a
metaphysical
that's an idea that is magic yeah it's
magic you're right we were doing a
little bit of research on this kind of
idea of like where does music come from
you know and and uh and you know we
wanted to know like
like
evolutionarily
where did music come like why what is
the adaptive advantage of music because
music is basically another form of
language
but it's a
uh it's you know a more cumbersome form
of language so that doesn't really help
us survive or anything i can tell you
right now how it helps us multiply reza
that's what i was just gonna say i was
just gonna say that there is no greater
meaning to music than to try to get laid
i have this i have this quote right here
this is this is darwin primeval man
probably first use his voice in
producing true musical cadences as do
some of the gibbon apes at the present
day and we may conclude that this power
would have been especially exerted
during the courtship of the sexes
music evolved to get us laid yeah
i don't know i think i think music is in
every culture of the world it's in every
you can go find some lost tribe in the
amazon or borneo or something like that
they'll have some kind of
form of music and
you know you know i'm not a i'm not a
materialist i i believe that uh you know
i believe in a higher power and i
believe in a magic in the universe
that's beyond the material that's beyond
molecules
and um i think there's something
truly mysterious about this human need
to express in song and rhythm
uh something
to express our humanity
and yes birds sing but you know they
they
they sing to mate and i i suppose that
you could kind of quantify what what
their songs are for but there's
something really
as mysterious as consciousness itself
there is a mystery underlying this
universal musical human impulse
yeah i i i wouldn't disagree with that
because um i feel like the significance
of it has has
grown
and it's become so important uh you know
to everybody in a way that it can't
necessarily really just be
to
reproduce or to survive or to evolve i
mean
i also think that like i personally i
try to be careful of
the magic of music uh because i think
very often that's the story that you get
told not you but you know that's that
those were some of the stories that i
would i was told
uh so i didn't figure out the truth you
know um i think robert johnson sold his
soul to the devil
uh because there were a lot of white
people who were real embarrassed that
they couldn't play like robert johnson
and so they said
he won't show us how to do that he sold
his
yeah it's like aliens with the pyramids
it's like no just accept the fact that
brown people built something you
couldn't [ __ ] build let's do that you
know
the magic is is the difference between
what we understand and
what's happening but you know i know
that's i know that's kind of depressing
well how do you start a song you're
writing a song i know this is probably
the tiredest question that musicians
ever get asked but
it's such a mystery to me because i i
don't you know i'm an artist and
uh but i wouldn't know how to
write a song you could put a gun to my
head i don't know that i could write a
song although
my my series of love songs to reza aslan
might fill an album
that's true but you know how to write a
song but but how do you start with an
image you start with a lyric a riff is
it does it always change is it a memory
is it a is it a longing in your heart
that needs expression do you tap into
that collective memory that you were
talking about sometimes i get on a wave
yeah every once in a while i'll feel
like i'm just riding something and
hanging on like a blackjack hand exactly
sometimes i feel like i'm just hanging
on you know and that is magical and i
won't say that my wife would [ __ ]
kill me if she heard me say that there's
no magic in that because there there is
there is um
but more often than not like if i was
gonna sit down and write a song right
now uh which i'm not but if i was going
to i would i would pick up a guitar and
i would start playing the guitar and i
would start humming a melody and um
i would get a little bit of a melody
first and then i would vocalize that uh
syllabically you know i would scan it
into some type of gibberish words like
scrambled eggs like paul was doing with
scrambled eggs when he woke up that
morning um
and then i would replace that you know
the majority of songwriting is edited
for me because
um
you know i wind up just immediately
going back and fixing and going back and
you take you know one step up and two
steps back or two steps up and one step
back and you finally get somewhere um
but sometimes it is a phrase like that
happens a lot too i take a ton of notes
just things that i say or things that i
overhear
i jot them down on my phone or on a
piece of paper in my computer or
something or i'll sing a voice memo to
myself i've got a whole bunch of voice
memos like uh the song traveling alone
on southeastern i was it was very
literal sometimes it's so literal that
it it makes me laugh that i think you
are a cheesy bastard you are an old man
in a club with a dog right now uh you
are so corny because this is really
what's happening to you and you're about
to write a song about it
so you were traveling alone yes i'm glad
i'm tired of traveling alone god that
sounds like a song i get tired of
traveling alone exactly and then you're
like oh you [ __ ] you can't you idiot
but that's that country music thing
where your heart is on your sleeve and
you sing it that's that part of country
music that is uh universal and beautiful
and courageous and courageous to say how
you earnestly feel without hiding behind
any kind of wit you know okay i hate to
put you on the spot and you feel free to
say no truly jason
do you have a guitar handy and can you
just strum a little bit and just
hum
something
as in in the context of you
how you would write a song just just
could you demonstrate this and by the
way uh dear listeners
uh i understood that jason's wife amanda
shires who was also a brilliant
violinist singer musician songwriter um
part of the uh
the highway women the high women highway
women the high women um
uh
she was a huge office and dwight fan so
i sent over a care package of like
signed bobble heads and
office bric-a-brac and i knew i was
going to call in that favor and this is
it i called in jc yes oh yeah i'm happy
to man really you got me uh
a lot of a lot of points on that because
that year she i was like what do you
want for christmas this year honey and
she was like
you know i want uh
this from dwight schrute and i was like
dwight schrute is not a real person
so i would start like
[Music]
to me that sounds a little bit like the
band like levon hill and robbie
robertson that sounds like the night
they drove old dixie down which
convene conveniently
that song has been canceled because it's
about uh the confederacy so what we
should do now if i were writing a song
would be write something to replace the
knight that drilled all dixie down
so now i have kind of a subject matter
so i would be like well let's write
something about that war that's not
celebrating the confederacy this is just
what i would do right now and make it
kind of sound like the night they drove
old dixie down
so that's the exercise is to like write
a write a replacement for that not that
i would ever do that
[Music]
but here we're changing the melody
a little bit later than we change the
chord because that's how we're creating
tension and release
so like if you're if you're walking down
from the c major
to the relative minor
and you're singing like a 5.
now if i if i took the melody down at
the same time as the chord change
it becomes piano man that's not what you
want you know you want something that
makes it more tense you know
[Applause]
[Music]
so the part of that sticks out to me
is that
[Music]
so that's the part i would probably
write first i would say
that's the part that's going to stick so
what are those words going to be
and then i would record that so i didn't
forget it
and i would work on
three syllables
you know
short word long word
or three short words
because if you do long word short word
it's going to sing in a different way
than it speaks and you're cheating you
know and people can hear that when
you're when you're cheating so i would
go short word long word
and then i would start looking for a
short word in a long word that had
something to do with the reality of
the story that was uh romanticized in
the beautiful song the night they drove
old dixie down by the band this is
amazing you know what just happened just
right there what happened it's the
perfect melding
of what we were just talking about right
so someone can watch what jason just did
and be like
yeah i mean i could see the inspiration
just kind of coming like why start with
that chord and and then suddenly
something familiar came out of it and
that that
like that was just you know it was it
just sort of felt right but listening to
him talk
what it was he talking about he was
talking about
the south
which is where he was where he's from
there was some church churchy feel there
to it which is how he grew up right
there's some r b feeling which is like
the theme right i'm gonna change the
theme
it's the it's the collective
consciousness right it's
it's a lifetime of experience that has
gone beyond any kind of real
conscious awareness of and it just comes
out and it looks like it was divinely
inspired
but in reality it is the sum total
of place
and spirit
and experience
and identity
and
the song comes out of there
but you know there's magic in keeping
yourself open
to those creative ideas you know and and
that's the part that i don't necessarily
understand because at this point after
writing songs for this long i have a a
switch that i flip well it kind of
always stays flipped to the creative
side now but i would never stop myself
never like that's the first
mistake you know that's the first rule
is don't ever cut yourself off if you're
making something creative try everything
be open to everything go for it if it
looks stupid nobody has to see it but
you you know
um
and that's where the magic is how do you
get your mind into that place how do you
accumulate the experience and the
knowledge to make what you want to make
not necessarily something that's good or
bad because then you're talking about
taste
which is another version of the
collective unconscious but you know to
make something that you want to make
once you know what you need to know
how do you keep access to that and it's
like
when i was working on that movie over
the summer the scorsese movie that movie
that scorsese movie that scorsese movie
you know that was something when i was
when i was acting in that scorsese movie
over the summer yeah ladies and
gentlemen love the listening audience
before we were recording
we were talking about uh i made a little
crack to jason i was like okay you can
let your fake southern accent go now and
let's have a real conversation
and he was saying how
robert de niro almost had the same
reaction wasn't sure if it was a real
accent or not while shooting on the
scorsese film i've been an actor for 30
years try i would do anything to be in a
scorsese film i once peed next to martin
scorsese at the golden globes okay
i once said hello to robert de niro i
would do anything to be in that movie
here i am struggling away trying to get
respect oh you you played this doofus on
the office you'll never be in a scorsese
movie you
[ __ ] idiot and you've got a face like
an old clown
i could play
a redneck
weirdo over here and learn your accent
isabel do you understand i know i
believe i believe it
let's hear that that's here
jason isabel
hey how y'all how y'all doing down there
in the what's it called like hot house
or the yellow orchid or something like
that what's it called
killers of the flower moon oh that's it
okay yeah yeah that's quite a flower
moon we got up there
see
boom i got i got no defense for that ray
i think rain if i if i may i think they
were like look we need someone opposite
leo dicaprio who's not going to take all
the attention away from oh the captain
yes that's exactly couldn't have you oh
maybe that's what it was yes it's not
the kind of movie where it's like this
it's not it's like right he's here they
needed somebody who was basically
furniture
yeah and you can't be furniture you
could be me but you can't be furniture
rain i can't be furniture thanks guys i
feel so much better you were saying you
were saying jason one of the things that
i have done that i'm the most grateful
for out of all the work i've ever done
my whole life was being out there on
this movie um
i wish i could tell you rain that it was
that it sucked but it was amazing but
one thing that i that i saw that blew my
mind was the fact that
there there are these uh
uh
actresses who are all they play sisters
they play osage sisters and they're from
various different
uh uh tribes around north america
they're they're not they're not osage
but they were playing osage sisters and
they learned the osage language for
their lines
and um
you know i noticed a lot of this movie
is very sad and a lot of the scenes
these women are crying you know
and of course the first time i saw that
i was like oh they're crying on cue this
is amazing this is such great acting but
then i realized after talking to them
about this that they were that was not
acting that was traveling
they were they were not acting like they
were crying they were reaching and
opening the door to the most horrible
traumatic experiences that they had ever
had and the fact that they had to stay
that close to that part of themselves
while they were shooting these scenes
just blew my mind because i thought you
just taught yourself to cry but really
you don't you taught
you know they had taught themselves to
be that open
you know and to allow themselves to go
to those places because they weren't
faking that [ __ ] they were bald i mean
it was insane
and and i asked about it and they were
kind enough to tell me you know that
they were going to these dark places in
their past and i was very
uh sort of moved by that you know
that
being able to access that and still keep
your head above water just as a human
person but you've you've gone to some
dark places yourself
in your life in your struggles with
uh alcoholism and drug abuse in your
journey to sobriety
so
was it easier for you to
write songs through the haze of
uh you know chemicals
oh no that was way harder because
there's kind of a myth of the tortured
artist who needs to be
on drugs in order to create this
brilliance and once you lose that crutch
then you've lost your
voice
yeah i was afraid of that but turns out
that was just the part of me that wanted
to keep on drinking and using drugs you
know
that that that that was the guy on my
shoulder going yeah you're not going to
be able to do this if you let me go i'm
your best buddy you know i'm the only
reason you can access these parts of
yourself
now i'm not going to lie to you and tell
you i didn't have to sort of re-learn
how to get there you know and and how to
open myself up and and you know because
when you're drunk you're mad and then
you're crying and then you're ecstatic
and you're all these things
you know so for a long time there yeah
it was it was there was a wall up and
and i had to learn how to make myself
vulnerable uh again and i still work on
that all the time every day um
you know but i definitely don't think
i mean look at my career before and
after you know southeastern was the
first album i made sober
um
and uh i mean that's
you know that was a big big turning
point for me
as far as every aspect you know
creatively and
just career and career terms you know
that's amazing jason thank you so much
for sharing your story with us
your thoughts
uh the the magic the muse
and uh and giving us a little uh musical
demonstration is unbelievable what a
what an incredible treat thank you for
uh exploring this question with us today
thank you for having me and uh yeah i'm
always happy to talk to you and and love
your work and and reza i i ran around
trying to tell people about zealot years
ago when i read it and nobody in
franklin tennessee wanted to hear what i
had to say about that book so i just
kept that little nugget of joy in my own
heart oh that's true i appreciate that
jason thank you man that book was a big
deal to me big deal before we let you go
um
we do a lightning round uh questions uh
first thing that comes into your mind uh
we're gonna pepper you with profound
and ridiculous questions and you're
going to
illuminate us
uh describe your soul in 10 words or
less
my soul
is
rubber what was the happiest day of your
life well my daughter was born it was
also the scariest it was both it was
happiest and scariest i love it when
those two emotions go hand in hand
that's the easy answer i mean
yeah that's how it's you feel alive for
real don't you what emotion do you wish
you could better control frustration
like that
it's like it's it's a it's a secondary
probably a tertiary emotion of of fear i
mean
that answer is always going to be fear
but uh
i wish that i was better at showing
people that i'm truly happy on the
inside uh because sometimes i do the old
male depression party and i'm a grumpy
big grumpy alabama man you know what
happens to us after we die
um
who cares
no one's ever answered that i like that
what is something very few people know
about you
i mean very few like a handful i love
dualipa what is america an experiment
the results aren't in yet
uh what book changed your life besides
zealot by reza aslan
yes
um available on paperback i think uh
shadow country by peter matheson
uh that might be my favorite piece of
fiction ever written and it just it just
taught me so much about how the story
changes depending on who's telling it
you're stranded on a deserted island
you have a record player and you can
bring three records sticky fingers
wait wait wait wait wait you would bring
sticky fingers over exiles on main
street over exile over exile oh yes
i've had this argument with a lot of
people uh
but you know i'm from muscle shoals
alabama and and uh
uh wild horses was recorded in muscle
shoals alabama all right you got two
more discs let's go time is money uh
equipment
nice
yeah equipment
what is that i don't know what that is
outcast yo oh rain isn't cool
is one thing you should know i think
equipment is a beautiful beautiful piece
of work and probably the complete robert
johnson recording is humanity doomed
i don't think okay it's kind of like you
know when people get a divorce and they
say their marriage failed
uh i think no it didn't it succeeded for
so long
you know
it just didn't last forever
i think humanity is blessed with the
experience of living on this planet that
we have made uninhabitable for ourselves
and yeah one day we'll be gone we're not
getting nothing not everything's doomed
but you know we've had this opportunity
to have some time uh in this form and
that's been really badass for a lot of
us if you could have coffee with 15 year
old jason isbell what would you tell him
don't drink coffee you're 15 years old
[Laughter]
what are you doing you're gonna be up
all night
[Laughter]
jason finally we like to end with what
is your life's biggest
big question what is right
and what is wrong
and you know it's a small question that
i answer every time i make a decision i
think or most of the time a lot of
things are just easy but
but i i wind up thinking you know what
is right and what is wrong
and i try to stop there once i've
decided that i like to act you know um
but yeah what are the stakes
in in
the battle between right and wrong um
not is it worth it to do the right thing
but why is it worth it to do the right
thing that's the question for me
well jason isbell i want to thank the
muses
for uh this conversation not you you
didn't have anything to do with it it
just came from outside
yeah you're just a conduit
i want to thank all the divine gods
slash goddesses uh who made this
conversation happen
uh this is really fascinating man thank
you so much thank you i hope i hope uh
you guys enjoyed talking with me because
i really enjoyed talking with y'all i
did this was a pleasure and an honor and
i can't wait to not see you in that
scorsese film
thank you rain yeah same here
you know uh
they have those classes master class
where you can watch bobby flay
cook a fish
you know or
venus williams do a tennis serve
um
watching jason is bill and i know it was
just a little fun little side riff that
we didn't have pre-planned at all but
just for those
seven minutes with his guitar
talking us through a songwriting process
and his thought processes
that was absolutely
incredible there was something so
um
mysterious and yet really practical at
the same time
you know it was very it was very
grounded very real very meat and
potatoes nothing airy fairy about it but
yet at the same time something kind of
beautiful beautiful and mystical going
on that was
that was i i feel privileged to have
witnessed that i i really i feel the
same i really loved it and so much of it
is about
i mean you know long-time listeners of
our podcast know that
one of the things that drives us is is
our refusal
to
give any you know
real uh
attention to this dichotomy right
material spiritual you know body soul
like that's not how we are we we think
that it's all the same right it's all
one thing and so it was so funny to have
a guest call us on it who was like
it's like no it's not it's not some you
know it's
mysterious you know muse
uh it's the collective unconscious which
in and of itself is mysterious
right like you don't need to go out
there to look for some metaphysical
existential
uh answer to where art comes from
it's already existential it's already
metaphysical from within you right that
the magic is inside of you i thought
that was really really beautiful that
was really fantastic and look i'm going
to be honest with you it kind of uh it
it brought me back to my uh
to my rockstar days i feel like maybe
jason and i oughta i mean is he looking
for an opening act i mean i can't i can
get the band back together again i can
call pike remember you still need to
prove to us that you were in the band
pike and i'm gonna need to hear
some beautiful dulcet tones some lyrics
from the band pike
what are you going to be singing from
which song yeah
the song is called untitled one of our
biggest hits she gets in the front row
the smell of fog machines makes a come
see now it could be like sexual it could
be you know what do you i mean you know
what are we talking about here
like a domino
you're in a christian rock band talking
about women coming
no if she came to the show
jesus christ reign
your
your mind immediately goes into the
garden my mind was in the gutter reza
having heard you sing i just have one
thing to say
can i join
pike
please i want to be a part of this
like as a roadie like you want to like
tune our instruments
no i don't want to be a roadie i want to
be in the band i want to sing harmony
with you i'll play any instrument
whatever you need bassoon whatever you
need you know every rock band does need
a bassoon
so you know this this question of
where inspiration comes from really
sparked a lot of conversation amongst
our listeners we you know we want to
know uh
what inspires you where do you think
inspiration comes from is it from within
is it from outside do you agree with
jason where it's about like a collective
consciousness that exists within us or
are you more like the greeks where you
think that it's the muses or some divine
source that that inspires you uh we got
a lot of answers to this question rain
really we got the top three here top
three answers about where
inspiration comes from okay great first
one is uh melissa hello raynan reza my
name is melissa
and i get my inspiration um so i love
writing i am a writer and i get my
inspiration when i go on walks
i
don't have anything in front of me
except for the environment and other
people and observing things and taking
in all the stimuli
and that makes me feel
like my mind can go in places
and and connect the dots and come up
with my own reality my own stories about
what i see is going on around me and
then
when i get home i have all this energy
and i put
hand to laptop and
my mind just explores because it's open
and not hampered by technology or
something else like social media in
front of my mind so that's where my
inspiration comes from nature outdoors
walking
that's it
the first thing that brought to mind is
um
i was reading this incredible article
not long ago that talks about the power
of walking
and that you know look our species is
what two three hundred thousand years
old and
we've always walked up until about i
don't know 50 years ago or so we stopped
walking yeah and then that's when
there's been this incredible outbreak of
uh this mental health epidemic and
anxiety and depression i'm not saying
it's a complete corollary but at the
same time there's something remarkably
healing about walking yeah um
and it's literally how it how it works
in our brain they've done brain studies
where right foot left foot right foot
left foot it kind of like it's like the
the therapy emdr where your neuro
impulses go from left hemisphere to
right hemisphere and back again there is
something
healing and soothing about the act of
walking and i
i couldn't agree with her more you know
it's funny i i have a friend uh
gabrielle caressi who's a phenomenal
poet and uh and she writes all of her
poems while walking
like she's she doesn't like you know she
doesn't have a piece of paper or pen or
she doesn't sit down somewhere
like she she writes while she walks so
it's a very common very common uh place
of inspiration here thank you very much
melissa we got one more person here this
is blair this is blair ellistan i'm a
toronto based colorist and what inspires
me is many things but most notably in my
profession the amazing world around me
landscapes architecture natural colors
of the world
people faces emotions
it's all right there in front of you
that dude needs to be on radio oh he's
got a great voice blair find yourself a
podcast but when he said colorist and
then he said and looking at the world
around me like the shampooers and the
hair stylists and the receptionist at
the front and the scissors and the
barbicide isn't that colorist maybe he
meant colorist like you know like
you know like film colorist thank you
for your beautiful voice and your
inspiration and
this quest that you have provided for us
to find out what a colorist does all
right let's do one more uh this is laura
my name is laura and i'm an interior
designer
it's hard to put my finger on what it is
exactly that excites me creatively but
when i see that certain thing whether it
be art
film or travel
i just have this feeling of excitement
it's inspirational it transports me and
it helps me think of new
interesting ways to translate it into my
into my job really
fantastic wow that's beautiful you know
i think everyone can be creative and uh
it's it's fantastic to hear these uh
stories and these examples of people
finding inspiration and creativity all
around them i think it's an important
message to keep relaying that
creativity and inspiration is just there
for us to find thank you listeners for
writing in for calling into our speak
pipe if you want to leave us a life's
big question
a thought on one of our episodes you can
contact us at speakpipe which is
speakpipe.com
metaphysicalmilkshake
and leave us an audio message we may use
it
and it will be delicious
thank you jason isbell for diving deep
with the metaphysical milkshake team
uh do you want more of life's big
questions find us on the socials please
at reza aslan and at rayne wilson and on
twitter at metamilkpodcast and instagram
at
metaphysicalmilkshake and let us know
your life's big questions we might
explore them on a future episode we
might bring you on a future episode to
be featured so please please write us
yeah and tell us where you fall on this
whole
where does music come from is it do you
believe in divine inspiration do you
believe in the muses uh or do you think
it's just a guy sits down with a guitar
and a pad and a piece of paper and a pen
and just
works it works it like he's working the
fry station at mcdonald's also remember
to follow rate and review metaphysical
milkshake on apple podcasts and wherever
you listen to podcasts we really rely on
your reviews
uh so thank you very much for that
please subscribe to metaphysical
milkshake on youtube channel and you can
watch us talking instead of just
listening to us talking
see you next week
she gets in the front room
the smell of fox sheets makes you come
thank you very much thank you thank you
dear lord come on that's that's that's a
hit that's a hit right there it's good
it's really really good
jason isbell call me
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubel cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by justin kyle original music is
composed by jeff tang
[Music]
i tell you what jason 100 000
i will dress up as dwight schrute and
make love to your wife do not let her
hear this
man come on like
can you cut that out of the
program yeah don't worry it's going we
will definitely edit that it's not it's
going in out a hundred thousand dollars
and possibly some of my pride we don't i
don't know how it's gonna work out but
it might cost me some of my pride but
think of the song that'll come out of it
though
but i'll get a song out of it
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you